how is it even possible that no one is
talking about this as I've shared in
recent videos the inexplicable
catastrophic water erosion that is
clearly visible throughout the Sahara
Desert is so extreme that even the
stripped Bedrock scarring from whatever
this mysterious flood event was can
easily be observed from space but the
only thing more bizarre than finding
such profound water erosion in the
middle of the Sahara Desert of all
places is the fact that virtually nobody
within the scientific or academic
Community seems to be aware of it much
less discussing it which I have to say I
find quite strange yet the signature
traits of a cataclysmic flood event are
visible to all who have eyes to see and
you certainly do not have to be a
geologist to distinguish the natural
characteristics of water striations but
thanks to the internet you can quite
literally access undergraduate course
curriculum in geomorphology that teaches
us exactly what water erosion over
Bedrock looks like now the reason why
this is so important to understand is
because according to everything we've
been taught involving the history of
climate change on Earth any recent
catastrophic water erosion in the Sahara
Desert is simply not supposed to exist
or even be possible leading many to
ignore this obvious fluvial erosion and
foolishly dismiss it as being created by
the wind and nothing more because after
all the idea of an ancient flood event
is apparently far too Fringe and pseudo
to entertain which I have to say is such
a bizarre and honestly lazy thing to
suggest on something that is so easily
verifiable I mean there are so many
places on Earth that are known for
consistently high wind conditions and
none of them have any sort of striations
such as those found in the Sahara and
the reason for this is because this is
simply not what wind erosion looks like
simply research the 10 windiest places
on Earth and then view them from
satellite imagery via the Google Earth
app and you will observe with your own
eyes that none of these locations have
any level of striations whatsoever in
fact the number one windiest place on
Earth is Commonwealth Bay in Antarctica
and if there was any type of geological
element that would make striations easy
to form it would be in snow and ice
rather than Bedrock yet you'll notice
that none of these striations exist
anywhere in Antarctica go down the list
of the windiest places on Earth will it
be Wellington New Zealand which is
number two or Bridge Creek in the state
of Kansas not far from Dodge City which
is the third windiest or Mount
Washington in the state of New Hampshire
at number four and go all the way down
the list and you'll notice the same
thing every time a complete and total
lack of striations of any kind make no
mistake the stripped Bedrock striations
found throughout throughout the Sahara
Desert were created by a force of water
just like they teach would-be geologists
in college like I always say look and
think for yourself we all have the
ability to fact check details from our
smartphones and laptops with simple
movements of our fingertips what an
amazing time to be alive am I right but
if comparisons are not convincing enough
the very fact that enormous quantities
of salt exist in all prior mentioned
areas of fluvial erosion is additional
corresponding evidence that seawater had
settled and later evaporated here
following whatever this mysterious event
was that blasted its way through the
Sahara like I mentioned in my prior
video this force of water even cut its
way through a twelve thousand year old
lava flow which is hard evidence that
this event happened far more recently in
our past than anyone thought possible
you can literally see the line of
erosion that cuts off and erases that
very lava flow which nobody else seems
to be discussing and speaking of things
that no one else seems to be talking
about and if everything I've shared so
far isn't enough to convince you that
the ocean was the cause of all this
erosion wait until you see what I found
on the other side of the world notice
those small white blemishes in the
middle of Australia those are Salt Flats
that make up the region of Lake air an
ancient Lake that sits 15 meters or
nearly 50 feet below sea level and
notice the unique geological pattern
that connects it to the North look at
all those striations identical to those
that we see in the Sahara and not only
that they are covered in salt and so
when you consider this Region's
elevation below sea level and that it
once obviously connected to the ocean at
the South it could not be more apparent
that a massive force of water once
blasted its way through the middle of
Australia as well this similarity is
highly significant considering that many
struggle to wrap their head around the
idea that the Sahara was blasted by the
ocean when much of the region is
currently about a thousand feet above
sea level at least that's where it is
today however that certainly was not
always the case as the evidence shows
and considering the consistent below sea
level elevation in this region of
Australia along with the profound
signatures of water-induced erosion and
along with the layer of salt that sits
on top of it in fact so much salt that
it can be clearly seen from space when
you tie all these fascinating details
together it makes it very easy for
anyone to understand that whatever
Happened Here Also happened to the
Sahara and it wasn't wind and by the way
it must be pointed out that whatever
this event was is not limited to the
Sahara because if you evaluate the
surrounding region you'll notice that
whatever this event was it clearly
ripped its way through the modern day
country of Sudan and Saudi Arabia and
the region of the Red Sea and Persian
Gulf respectively in fact if you expand
your search
you'll start to realize that whatever
this event was seems to have originated
either directly out of the Mediterranean
Sea or perhaps even north of it this
raises many questions and I'm going to
explore this topic thoroughly in an
upcoming video where I will share more
thoughts on what may have actually
happened to cause all this but I have to
say we must consider that the nature of
certain cataclysmic events on Earth may
very well be way worse than most people
ever considered but if there was one
takeaway from all of this it's the
realization that the Sahara Desert was
blasted by the ocean tens of millions of
years more recently than what was
previously known and nobody within the
scientific or academic Community seems
to even be aware of it which is
startling because the implications of
whatever this event was is truly a game
changer in our understanding of Earth's
true geological history and this cannot
be ignored leave a comment and share
your thoughts on all of this do you
really think that these area areas of
stripped Bedrock striations with salt on
top of it was created by the wind or is
it far more likely that a cataclysmic
flood event that has somehow eluded
scientists and researchers what happened
in our ancient past but with that
question I'll close it up here my name
is Jimmy corsetti my channel is called
bright Insight hit the like button and
subscribe and stay tuned to another
fascinating video real soon take care
everyone